so it's always a little bit of that and
sometimes you have to go you know what
i'm not doing that um
i did a show in the very beginning years
ago
called high cliff manor with shelly
fabre and steve mccaddy and
um and it was about it was a pilot it
was a series
um and uh i played um
a voodoo priest um who had crossed the
uh the atlantic in a canoe um
me and steve mccaddy and uh so every
other line was moana
and uh and i had gold teeth and
uh earring and um
no no sablana it was just weird and i
really i mean i was me and the kids you
know things were really tight and i
wanted the job it was paying more money
that i haven't made and i'm like
i went in and uh and i got the part
and i worked on it for about three days
and then
i just i just had a hard time you know
just so the goal all that stuff
and so finally i went to uh the
producers and um
i said you know i i i can't do this
i mean personally his name was uh bamboo
and uh and i said you know i they're
guys who would jump up and down to get
this role but
i i i can't so i just quit and wow
and uh they called me that night and
said hey we don't understand i said well
listen i
you know i got kids man and i just you
know i i can
try to work around something but this is
just no i can't do it so and i'm not mad
i'm not i'm not saying you're wrong i'm
just saying i can't do it and i i can
tell you
most of my friends would be happy to do
it for the money they were paying me
so the next day they called and said
well listen ernie uh we really want this
to work so
how about we change the name uh and from
bamboo his name is smite
and uh we still like the the voodoo
priest thing but he's a voodoo priest
who
graduated from oxford so and and
he has a british accent and if we can do
the
um i mean we don't have cebuana
and so they did no gold teeth let's get
rid of the gold teeth
uh in the earring who does that
you know so wow we're able to work it
out
and normally you know you you're so
angry that you go
you call them races you see a bunch of
awful things and now
is a battle and now everybody hates
everybody
but i think the fact that um i learned
that you can just say no i'm not
comfortable and
and i don't want to do it and people
will try to work with you